[Music]
what's up everybody how you doing today
if you haven't already don't forget to
sign up for the new giveaway that I'm
doing that link is down in the
description and I'm actually going to
give away two prizes this month on the
same day and there are five different
ways to submit an entry which will give
you more chances to win so even if
you're a longtime subscriber make sure
you go sign up anyway that way you're
entered for sure thank you now let's get
started are you completely mad
you thought alright alright you thought
I heard you the first time what the
little claim aren't you how old are you
boy okay
things I do for love today I want to
further discuss something that I talked
about in my most recent theon greyjoy
video and if you haven't seen that video
I give a few examples of some things I
think Theon can do in order to complete
his story arc which would be him ending
with something heroic even though he's
one of the most unlikely characters to
do so vielen is one of the only
remaining characters alive that knows
Jamie Lannister is the one who was
responsible for pushing bran out of the
tower window at Winterfell
but what if Theon isn't the one to
reveal this information to the starters
it would definitely be a good
opportunity for Theon to smooth things
over with the remaining Starks even
though he already did help sponza escape
from the grasp of Ramsay Bolton but also
saying bran may figure this out on his
own I actually asked this question last
night during cows live streaming but we
only briefly discussed it so now I want
to take the time to give my opinion on
this matter and we know that when Jaime
Lannister push bran out the window it
was a pivotal moment in the story in a
major turning point for both characters
story arcs and unfortunately for brand
he has no knowledge or memory of what
actually happened that day
ever since bran has begun to harness his
powers of becoming the new three-eyed
Raven I've been wondering if brain will
eventually have this big revelation and
find out or remember what actually
happened that day and if he does what
would be his course of action against
the Lannisters most importantly Jaime
Lannister and although it's brand's
destiny to be pushed out that window
will he still be able to forgive the man
that is responsible for crippling him
for the rest of his life I think there
is a very good chance that bran will
learn of this by the end of season 7 or
the beginning of season 8 and I know
some people may be thinking is this even
going to be important to the story what
purposes are going to serve it brained
us figure this out or remember this well
that all depends on the show writers how
important do they want to make this -
the ploy personally I think this needs
to be resolved in one way or another I
think this was too big of a moment in
the story for this not to have any kind
of closure and it's earthy and Jaime
don't have a Romeo and Juliet type of
ending
and Jamie does eventually leave sir see
he's going to need a place to go and
unless he goes into seclusion
occasionally walk which I don't think
he's going to do he's going to end up
being tied back into the northern story
we know that Jamie has already distanced
himself from Cersei in the books but in
the show it appears that Jaime still
loves her deeply and has stuck by her
side no matter what
and even though Jaime gave Cersei that
look at the end of season six he's more
than likely going to still stand by her
decision even if he doesn't agree with
it but there is going to come a time
when Jaime reaches his breaking point
when Cersei will have taken things too
far which is going to force Jaime to end
the relationship whether that be by
death or by abandonment and I think most
people believe that Jaime is going to be
the one to kill Cersei but if he doesn't
and he just abandons her he's more than
likely going to seek out his brother
Tyrion or one of his only friends
Brienne but the problem is both of those
characters are going to be tied in with
the north story and I could easily see
Jon Snow being eager to execute Jaime
when he learns that he was the one who
attempted to murder brand but how will
the remaining strokes going to find out
that Jaime did this if they aren't told
by Theon well we do know that brain is
right outside the wall with mirror read
and I'm assuming when season seven
begins brain will be wanting to find Jon
so he can tell him what he saw in his
vision at the Tower of joy plus I'm sure
he really misses his family and being at
home but that would just be an extra
motivation to get him there I think when
bran knows it's safe to go back to
Winterfell that's where he's going to go
and when he does get there he's going to
tap into the weirwood tree out in the
godswood while he is there personally I
think that's how brain is going to learn
of what happened to him that day because
he hasn't been able to remember ever
since the fall but I think since that
weirwood tree is in the godswood in
Winterfell he's going to be able to see
everything that happened at the Tower
that day he was pushed by Jaime
Lannister and it's going to be one of
those big holy [ __ ] moments too when
brand sees it all play out in another
vision
but as bran going to seek vengeance
against the Lannisters for them I'm not
so sure deep down I don't feel like bran
is the type to order Jaime's execution
but if he did I'm assuming bran would be
the one
area of the sentence since his father
did tell him one of my favorite quotes
from this story the man who passes the
sentence should swing the sword I'm also
thinking now that brain is learning that
things are one's destiny and things
happen for a reason
so that other things can happen more
important things then bran might lead
Jamie lives I don't think he's ever
going to truly forgive him or allow him
to roam freely throughout the north but
I don't feel a brand will want to kill
him for this but another question is
will it even be up the brand whether
Jamie lives or not John snow could
resolve this problem before bran ever
finds out about it but there is
something else I think that needs to be
mentioned here too but it is a spoiler
so proceed with caution
if all the reports are true we're going
to see a big parlay seen at the end of
season seven with nearly twenty
characters and two of those characters
will be Jon Snow and Jamie Lannister and
they are going to come in contact with
each other once again and if you
remember correctly Jamie Lannister was
an [ __ ] to Jon Snow when they first
met so now that Jon Snow is in a
position of power and Jamie only has one
hand John's going to be able to kick his
ass now he isn't going to let this King
sling sister [ __ ] one-handed banded
push him around anymore
and the potential was still there for
Theon to tell Jon Snow about this
information he received from lady
Catelyn herself when she figured out it
was the Lannisters in the tower that
bran fell from so when Jon and Filan had
this altercation on the beach this could
be the time
Theon reveals this to the Starks and if
John learns about this then what is
going to happen at this dragon pit team
do you think Jon could execute Jamie
on-site if given the opportunity either
way this is going to make for a very
exciting scene when these two characters
meet again and I can't wait to see how
this goes down at the dragon pit you're
going to be able to cut that tension
with a knife
personally and I know a lot of people
are going to disagree with me about this
but I actually enjoy what Jaime
Lannister brings to the story so I would
like to see him continue his story arc
as well and make a full turnaround which
would be him being known as a
but as an honorable man even though
right now it appears that there is no
way in hell that can happen is there
anything Jamie can do to be forgiven by
everybody would say van Branagh John's
life somehow be enough for everyone to
see Jamie in a different light it's not
going to be an easy task if the story is
heading in that direction but I want to
see him kill or leave Cersei then team
up with his brother or even get back
with bran and repay for his mistakes by
helping the north during this war for
the dawn 2.0 Jamie will be crossing
paths with the Starks again eventually
he's going to have to face the music for
what he did that day and I do think his
crime is absolutely punishable by death
and if anyone does execute him for this
I think Jon Snow would be the one to do
it but I can also see bran sparing his
life depending on what other visions
brand could get he can learn more about
what happened that day Jaime killed the
Mad King or if Jaime killed Cersei to
save King's Landing and possibly even
save Jon if he's actually in the city
that day
Cersei besides the nukid brain could
potentially see all of this and allow
Jaime to live if the day would ever come
that Jaime is in a vulnerable position
around the Starks or maybe none of this
happens and Jaime kills himself after he
kills Cersei who really knows this is
all just speculation of course but I do
want to see this get resolved before the
end I think it was too important of a
moment for it not to get an ending but
anyways give me your thoughts on this
topic I've been wondering how this would
end for a very long time now tell me if
you think this will ever be resolved
between Jaime and Brienne and tell me if
you think brain is going to figure this
out on his own whether that be through a
vision or if he just happens to remember
it one day and what will brain or John
do when and if they ever find out will
they seek justice or let it go I'm
curious to see what other people think
about this so thanks for spending the
time with me today
I do appreciate everyone for watching
this if you have anything to add then I
will see you down in the comment section
bye